mira
[Música
] greets héctor mejía with the
headlines for today, tuesday, december 19,
more than 860
new cases of coronavirus and 21 deaths were reported
in the state of nevada officials say
that the figures for monday showed an
average less than what was  had
recorded in recent weeks but that
this was perhaps due to sites
closing for the holidays and after
days of declining hospitalizations
these numbers have risen again
as more and more people are
receiving the
coronavirus vaccine in the valley  of las vegas'
on Monday the health district received
more than 12 thousand doses of the vaccine
manufactured by modern in total the
medical centers of southern nevada have
received 40,000 vaccines currently
immunization efforts are
in the first phase which allows you to
receive  the injection to people who
work in the public health sector and
to the most vulnerable people despite the fact that
the president of the 'u'
signed  bill to stimulate
the economy
thousands of unemployed Nevadans
scheduled to receive their benefits
may have to wait more
weeks to receive their funds the new
law includes an extension to
unemployment benefits further
includes the distribution of an
additional $300 per week  For those people who are already
unemployed,
the unemployment department here in the
state has already said that for this to happen,
the labor department will have to
guide the states and that this could take
at least two weeks and is approaching the
New Year's holidays, the center of
conventions seeks that 2021 be received
in a healthy way for now the city
has no events planned in the
hotel zone but the freemont tour
experience in the city's downtown
will be open, however they will not have
live music on any of its
stages on freemont street  will be
charging $25 to get in
now the only fireworks
planned  it's the plaza hotel now
a look at the weather forecast
mostly sunny with a little bit of a view
for today tuesday temperatures will
reach 55 degrees for today
and tonight clear skies with
cool temperatures around 35 degrees have
a nice day i am  héctor mejía and this
was his informative credo by liu xiao in
spanish
[Music]